creating an ml model in a notebook can
be quick and straightforward
but when you need to expand your ml
workflow to be sustainable and scalable
things can get more complex in previous
videos we've talked about pipelines and
how you can create
manage and reproduce your workflows at a
high level
let's break it down by walking through a
model that we'll later use in a keyflow
pipeline
[Applause]
[Music]
today we'll go through the details of a
sample ml model
you can check out other keyflow samples
in the link below
first set up a notebook server running
on kubeflow if you need a refresher
check out our previous videos on how to
do that next
clone the github repo linked below and
access the chicago crimes research
notebook
this notebook walks through a model that
we'll use as a part of a kubeflow
pipeline in the next video
so let's walk through how the model
actually works the model uses
chicago daily crimes data to forecast
how many crimes are expected to be
reported
the next day based on how many were
reported over the previous days
once the dependencies are installed the
first step is to query the data table
sitting in bigquery for daily crimes
over time
then download it into our jupyter
notebook
next you can visualize the data as a
line plot named
daily crime reports to give you an idea
of the actual values over time
to prepare the data for a model you need
to pre-process the data
since this is a sequence model you need
to split data sequentially to avoid
potential bias
with time-based data you want to make
sure you're not feeding the model data
that happened
after the prediction window then define
the percent of data you should use for
your training
eighty percent and the number of
observations used to predict the next
observation
our window size is seven in other words
you'll be using the prior seven days
worth of data to predict the next day's
crime count
when we pre-process the data we'll split
it up into the training and evaluation
data sets
and then normalize the data to avoid the
influence of any outliers
in order to begin training our model you
need to reformat our training data set
this generates an input function that
specifies features and labels
whether to shuffle the data number of
epochs and batch size
the resulting data set can be fed
directly to the model for training or
evaluation
then create a model for regression which
returns a compiled model
an object that we'll use to train now
you can begin training an evaluation
by passing in the training data set
validation data set
and finally train the model using those
it returns the trained model
once you specify batch size learning
rate and number of epochs
you can run the train and evaluate
function to get the final model
to evaluate the model take the trained
model and feed it the other 20
of evaluation data finally you can plot
the model's prediction outcome and
compare it to the actual counts
looking pretty good in the next video
we're going to take
this model and create an ml application
using kubeflow pipelines
stay tuned
you